turning to right now Major League
Baseball and we have our friend back
here on the show from MLB Network dan
please Ike how are you dan rich it's
good to talk to you again can you
believe we're ready to tee up another
season I know it's time to talk to you
about the World Series man time goes
fast I know and I want to talk to you
about that I know you're not a public
health official in you and you're you
know you you and I are just living life
trying to make heads or tails about
what's what's happening in the world so
let's let's get into I guess the outside
of the coronavirus world
and in terms of injuries that are
happening right now how serious is
what's going on with with Verlander in
Houston and you know I think it's it's
you know there's a lot of teams right
now the Yankees look like they're
compromised at any time restroom you get
the spring training when there's about
two weeks left and guys have to miss
time and they're worried about beginning
the season on time there there's always
a caution and particularly the guy like
Verlander that has a lot of mileage on
that arm and a lot of people three or
four years ago thought that this guy the
best baseball was in the rearview mirror
and he's had a resurgence the last two
or three seasons and it would be a big
blow to the Astros who have enough going
on outside of the game of baseball
they've had an off season for the ages
and that's why rich I think it's going
to be a very difficult year for the
Houston Astros you know and I don't mean
this in a joking way but a lot of times
and I was I played for 18 years and we
all want to think how cool it would be
to play for the Yankees right to wear
the pinstripes but there's that bubble
that comes with playing with the Yankees
they're there there's no franchise and
the Red Sox may be close the fans in
Philly can be tough but in the game of
baseball you know everybody wants to be
a Yankee well yank the Yankees outside
of New York they're hated everywhere
that they go right you either love the
Yankees or they hate the Yankees and I
kind of get the feeling like when I
think of the Astros they're gonna get a
chance to feel what it's like to wear
the pinstripes going into Fenway Park
because every ballpark that the Astros
go in 2020 they're the enemy right now
in it it's unfortunate because this is a
bad analogy and I've taken some heat for
it but I'll explain it I thought the
2016 Chicago Cubs they were a team that
was hard
- like them Anthony Rizzo Kris Bryant
the list goes on and on they did they
were a fun team to root for and there
wasn't really any villains and that's
kind of how you and I deal in that
national level we deal with a lot of
players on a lot of different teams in a
lot of different sports and this Astros
team was a team that they were they were
easy to like they made it easy for guys
like you and I you know they were they
were they were outspoken and they talked
and they had they had all the things
that you wanted they had personality
they had you know home run trots they
had celebrations and the dugout
everything that that baseball wants to
be celebrating now you know let the kids
play and let's have fun and forget that
old way and you know act like you've
done it before have fun and laugh and
now all of a sudden rich these guys
they're walking around with a giant
target on their back and I'll tell you
what amazed me I was a guest instructor
with the Phillies the first week of
spring training before pitchers and
catchers reported and not just in
Philadelphia but guys around the league
I've never seen a group of players more
angered more angry at this than the
steroid era and I played in the steroid
era that is it any more subsided do you
think or it's just it's still it's time
I don't think you know what I think
maybe there are other stories now that
have taken place to where we're not
worrying about the garbage can and the
banging but there are going to be up
against it rich because there are a lot
of I mean just think the first homestand
that they go and if they have a terrible
road a homestand and you know Bregman
goes 1 for 12 and the natural
inclination is to say well now they're
not cheating and they're not getting the
signs they're not going to be able to
win for losing and that's why I think
they're very vulnerable and boy that
makes things for the Oakland A's this
might be the year that the A's win the
West
no kidding dan please Zack MLB Network
here in the Rich Eisen show I've said
over and over again if I was a pitcher
I'd rather face somebody who's hopped up
on whatever you know fertility drug gets
you know mixed with a horse tranquilizer
and gets shot in their right glute
rather that person with a trapezoid head
be standing there than the person who
knows what pitch is coming now I'm
asking a natural form you know that's a
great analogy and I get where you're
going but that's the life of a pitcher
yes you're right
I mean if I'm a pitcher and you make
your living and you don't have heard
this and it's such a lame analogy well
the hardest thing to do is in a round
ball with a round bat and hit it square
but to get to that level we're talking
about the most elite of the elite
players that get to the big league level
so most of them can hit a fastball and
if you can't hit a breaking ball you're
gonna hang around in triple-a and some
guys aren't but they learn to adjust but
if you know what's coming and
particularly in the day and age that
baseball is now high velocity more
bullpens in baseball have guys throwing
95 and above if you don't throw 95 and
above you don't get a look there are
very few Kyle Hendricks in baseball
right now right handers that throw 88 to
91 that can sink it cut it guys that you
and I grew up watching that could you
know it was a more of an art now it's
about overpowering and in game where
that's where it's played if you know
that you're either looking for 98 or
you're looking for something off-speed
it makes it a lot easier I'm not saying
that you're going to get a hit every
time but I go back to the one playoff
game and Tom Verducci our colleague here
and he works for Fox also the game 5 I
believe that Kershaw was knocked out of
the fifth inning yeah there was some
there I can't remember the exact number
but over 40 breaking ball 0 and swings
and misses one what swung and missed at
0 you find out alarming of course and
that's part of this damn free sac here
and that's part of why this is still
alive this does this this cheating
scandal is still gonna obviously
manifest itself on the road when
Houston's on the road and places like
Oakland here in Southern California with
the Los Angeles Angels when they do show
up in New York and September by the way
so that's where that'll spark back again
the Dodgers whoever makes it for me
Astros for the all-star game has got to
be here in the home of the Dodgers for
the Midsummer Classic so it's gonna crop
up throughout the months of the season
and the reason why it's not going to go
away is twofold one is because Jim crane
the owner of the Astros
so manifestly awful at trying to address
this subject not once but twice that's
number one and number two number two is
we still don't know we still do not know
what exactly was utilized by the Astros
in that 2017 post season we don't know
if it was the World Series we don't know
if it was the ALCS we don't know if it
was the ALDS but we do know the
Commissioner believes it happened and we
still don't know the exact instance we
can parse it with video and Twitter and
social media but we did I would love for
the Commissioner just come out and say
here's the evidence that we got this is
transparent this is where we saw it in
the postseason so at least maybe some
party that believes they are aggrieved
we're Dodger fans one a long you know
hoist a blue asterisk on a flag when the
Astros come in for for any for any
all-star festivities at least we know it
we have no evidence happened in the
World Series at least we were nothing
and I think what surprised a talking
with players throughout baseball that I
think rich they were everybody in every
sport is looking for that edge right and
I think every guy every team every
player knows the difference between
right wrong and I think what has
irritated the other 29 teams and when
you get guys speaking out I mean very
rarely Mike Trout Kris Bryant Anthony
Rizzo you know not guys that are over
the top verbal they you really don't
hear much from those guys I just think
rich that the other 29 teams and this
isn't coming from I initially thought
the wave was going to be a bunch of
beaten up pitchers that had their brains
beaten out but it hasn't been it and
that's the part that has alarmed me but
I think what it this is just my my
estimation of talking to players is all
teams were trying to gain an edge
whether you're getting the signs
stealing them from second base third
base whatever it is but I think the
level that the Astros went to that's
what the players are taking offense of
like listen guy said guys and teams have
been trying to get signs from third-base
coaches and from pitchers and catchers
that you know expose the signs they
don't cover it up hold the glove leave
their legs open first and third base
coats can look in and see what
coming if you're using the same set of
signs that's been part of baseball since
moby dick was a mental right but I think
the level that the Astros took it to in
real time is what fury ated a lot of
players and it still does Dan I always
love our chats appreciate the time we'll
get you back on in a couple weeks when
the opening day is upon us and hopefully
we smell the the the cut grass in the
stadium Stan we look forward to that
you got it rich you got it I'm talking
to you right back at you at police act
19 dan please sack right here on the
Rich Eisen show that's so you can follow
him on Instagram and Twitter and of
course on MLB Network studio analysts
one of the best it's done it for over
ten years now